This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.
All right. Hello and welcome everyone to
Daily with Doc and Becca. My name is
Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I am going to be
your host for today. We are gonna have a
fantastic show with pharmacist Ben
Fuches and we are gonna talk about
uh the link between nutrition and brain
and your brain and um he's going to do a
little bit of a deep dive into that and
then we're going to have questions.
And this program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com.
And if somebody referred you to this
program, please get back with that
person because they are going to be your
primary point of contact. And um also
this program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not meant to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA and
testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Real
results may vary and may not be typical.
We do not make any claims for income or
health. As an empowered individual, you
do have choices. So that's why we're
here is to offer you some choices.
All right. So, I'm gonna go ahead and
bring pharmacist Ben on the screen with
me if I can find him. There he is,
hiding in the back.
All right. How are you today, Ben?
>> Hey, good to see you, Ruth Ellen and
Marilyn and Albert and Mary and AJ.
Where's AJ? I don't see.
So, what's going on? What are we gonna
talk about today?
>> We're good.
>> Yeah, I know what we're gonna talk about
today. I just want you to say it.
You want me to say it? Okay. You're
going to explore the powerful link
between nutrition and cognitive
function.
>> Yes. Um I used to my dad had dementia. I
know I've told a story before, but it's
appropriate. Um and he had it pretty
severely. But when I go and when I went
to visit him in the nursing home, I
would bring him Beyond Tangy Tangerine
and I'd fill him up a glass and he'd
drink the Beyond Tangy Tangerine and
right in front of my eyes, he would just
bloom, just blossom. The brain burns
through more nutrients than any other
part of the body. It's constantly
burning through nutrients. And anytime a
part of the body is very nutrient
intensive, it's going to get the maximum
benefits from nutrition. And that's the
brain. In fact, in many ways, dementia
is a brain nutritional deficiency. And
you don't have to have full-blown
dementia to have a brain nutri a brain
nutritional deficiency.
um Warner Cororsov syndrome, alcoholic
psychosis, attention deficit disorder,
emotional issues, um a uh uh dyslexia.
These can all be in many ways either
caused by or exacerbated by nutritional
deficiencies, particularly in electrical
nutrients. Uh the specific we wanted to
talk about was Parkinson's disease. I
found an article last week and I sent it
to AJ. Um AJ, you can post it if you if
you have it. if you have it. AJ's AJ's
gone dark here. Uh, and it's on park
it's on Parkinson's disease and um, and
dementia. I'm sorry, Parkinson disease
and vitamin nutritional supplements. And
surprise surprise, B vitamins, vitamin
C, vitamin E, all of these um, all of
these at least in this study have been
shown to help improve u improve improve
the um, improve the movement disorders
are associated with Parkinson's. There's
also by the way a phenomenon known as
Parkinson's dementia which is deme one
of the along with Alzheimer's dementia
Louisi body dementia it's one of the
more common forms of of brain dementias
and same idea nutritional
supplementation can go a long way
towards helping with cognitive function
and the reason I thought this was
important is because we get diagnosed
with health challenges we automatically
believe there's no alternative but to go
the medical model and as anybody who has
Parkinson's knows and anybody who has
Alzheimer's disease knows or any kind of
dementia knows there's nothing in the
doctor's magic bag of tricks that can
improve Parkinson's disease or um or
dementias interestingly I've been
working with Parkinson's patients for
many years and no surprise if you've
heard us speaking before
people have Parkinson's disease have
longstanding digestive health issues
particularly constipation
so um one of more important things to do
in addition to supplementing with Beyond
Tangy Tangerine. All these vitamins by
the way that are in the study, they're
in Beyond Tangy Tangerine and then the
healthy brain and heart pack. So if
somebody out there is wondering where
they can leverage the nutrients that are
uh that are highlighted in this paper
for Parkinson's, healthy brain and heart
pack, even just the Beyond Tangy
Tangerine. But in addition, what I find
great success with, and I've worked with
many Parkinson's patients, is digestive
support, patching up a leaky gut, food
diary, eliminating problem foods. I want
I'll talk about food diary here in a
second because I had an interesting
experience this week with a food diary.
>> Uh and then um we talked about this on
Monday. Fecal transplants and and
actually fecal capsules have been used
to treat Parkinson's. Fasting can help
with Parkinson's disease. And also
interestingly, people who have um
Parkinson's disease tremors will
typically not have tremors when they're
taking a warm bath. When the body is
relaxed, relaxing the muscles will also
relieve Parkinson symptoms. And
activating the parasympathetic nervous
system in general will activate or
relieve Parkinson symptoms such as slow,
deep, rhythmic breathing. That's really
really important for Parkinson's
patients because people have Parkinson's
disease tend to be brea tend to breathe
shallow because um they don't have the
um they don't have competent muscle
competent respiratory muscles. They have
to really work at breathing at breathing
long and deep. So there's lots and lots
of health uh health strategies, ways
that you can improve all cognitive
health issues from Alzheimer's dis
Alzheimer's dementia to movement
disorders to Parkinson's disease to um
full-blown psychotic episodes like
wornoff syndrome or alcoholic psychosis.
One of the all-time great brain
nutrients for dementia or for
Parkinson's disease is vitamin B1
thamin. And in fact, if you do have
alcoholic psychosis, thamin is the
treatment of choice. And they actually
give you thamin in the drunk tank or the
the um wherever you go to dry out. And
that is literally a a strategy for
reversing psychosis, alcoholic
psychosis. And you got to wonder how
many people thamin is used by the body
to process sugar. And under conditions
of lots of of high sugar intake, thamin
deficiency is common. People who um eat
a lot of junk food can be deficient in
tham. And you got to wonder how many
people think that they have cognitive
decline issues or dementia issues or
kids who have ADD issues when all they
really are experiencing is something as
uh as simple as a thamin deficiency.
Thamin is a and also thamin plays a very
important role in digestive health too.
And that u just further highlights the
relationship between that digestive
system and Parkinson's disease. You can
use the same nutrient to treat both um
chronic constipation and Parkinson's.
And um I saw a note on one of our
videos. I think it was the one we did
last Monday. Somebody was saying how um
Ben always says don't do this for that,
but you know, sometimes he'll give a
long list of nutrients that or products
that you use after um somebody asks a
question about a health challenge. I
don't know if you saw that comment. So,
if that person is on is on the uh call
today, they should know that it's true.
You don't want to say take this for
that. That being said, there's a lot of
supplements that can be used to treat
specific health challenges. Not so much
because they're specific health
challenges because they're health
challenges. But people ask about
specific questions and then I I talk
about using specific nutrients. That's
because those nutrients are important
for overall health, not necessarily just
for that specific health issue. So,
thamin is important for Parkinson's.
That's true. But it's also important for
ADD and it's also important for
emotional issu uh emotional problems uh
um mood dysregulation also for um in
addition to um full-blown psychosis also
just dementias and as I said uh probably
by uh Parkinson's disease or other
movement disorders. And then another
thing I was going to talk about I got a
had an interesting experience this week
with a gal who did a food diary. you
know, we're always talking about food
diaries. And while it sounds like a food
diary would be simple, as it turns out,
it's really not that simple. So, I was
working with this gal, young lady. She's
about 26 years old, very smart, very
buttoned down, very organized lady. And
uh she had she had uh severe acne on her
back and on her face. And I talked to
her and you know, of course, as is
always the case, she said, "Yeah, I
bloat. I have gas. I have digestive
problems." And I say always the case
when there's severe skin problems. Um,
so I had her do a food diary and she uh
I said, "Call me back in a week after
you've done your food diary." So she
called me back in a week and I said,
"Oh, well, what'd you find out?" She
said, "I can't find any relationships
between the foods I'm eating and um and
my breakout or the foods I'm eating and
my digestive problems." And so I I was
kind of surprised because that didn't
make any sense to me. I said, "All
right, why don't you send me the food
diary?" So she sent me this food diary
and she had it really done really well.
It was real organized. page. Uh the page
was split down the middle and on the
left hand side was all the foods she ate
in blue ink and then on the right hand
side was her digestive symptoms in red
ink and she was eating things. You know,
this is goes to show you how sometimes
we take for granted how little people
understand about foods. She was eating
beans and rice and spam and and um and
corn and burritos and cereal and ice
cream and cheese and you know classic
trigger foods. There's other trigger
foods of course but these were classic
trigger foods. And then in red ink she
had bloating, constipation, gas and I
had a whole list of digestive symptoms.
And I said to her how you told me that
you didn't notice a relationship. She
says yeah I don't know. I I didn't see a
relationship. So she actually saw that
she had digestive problems after she ate
foods, but she didn't make the
connection. And this was not a dumb
person. This was a smart person. And
this goes to show everybody who is
helping who is help who are helping
clients, people who are working with
longevity and patients themselves, how
hard it is to make connections. So if
you're out there and you say your
patient or you say your client to a food
diary and they come back and say, "Oh, I
have no connection. there's no
relationship or if you ask your patient
they have digestive health issues
associated with foods. Oh no, I don't
have any digestive health problems. You
have to probe. You have to dig deep. And
the Bible says by their fruits you will
know them. And I say where there's smoke
there's fire. If you have simp if you're
symptomatic particularly uh skin
symptoms and somebody says I don't have
any digestive health issues don't
believe it. Not because they're lying
and not because they're stupid, but
because we just don't make the
connections between what we're doing in
our lives and how our bodies show up.
But as we talked about a lot, it's
deductive reasoning. If you have a
circle and that circle is closed and
everything operates pristinely and
perfectly within that circle and then
you open the circle and introduce things
into that circle, you're going to cause
disturbances. The body is a finely tuned
machine. And while there's adjustment
mechanisms that pull the ups down and
the downs up, call that homeostasis, the
body is a is a finely tuned system that
operates within very tight windows,
very tight specifications.
And so if you're introducing things in
the body into the blood through the
digestive tract that disrupt chemistry,
there's no way eventually there's no way
you're you're not going to have some
kind of some kind of symptoms, some kind
of symptom. If when they make computer
chips, they have to wear hazmat suits
basically where they there there's no
way they can possibly breathe into the
computer chip. They have special
hepailters and for computer chips
because if a piece of dust gets in the
computer chip it destroys a computer
chip. The body is much the same way.
When a piece of dust something as simple
as a piece of dust gets into the
bloodstream if it's not handled
correctly you're off to the disease
races. And that is something that we
have to come to grips with because our
food supply has been completely
corrupted over the last 140 150 years.
And today's foods did not exist a
century and a half ago. So there's
really no way for most of us not to have
disruptions at the level of the
digestive system and ultimately the
level of the blood and the organs given
the kind of foods that we're all eating
even if we're eating healthy which most
of us don't. So, just assume that you
have a digestive health problem,
particularly leaky gut, which um AJ I
don't I don't see AJ, but uh if you
could send that if you had that article
on leaky gut and um chronic disease. I
sent AJ an article a couple weeks ago
about written by a physician who
actually went out and said all chronic
diseases are associated with a leaky
gut. You don't need to have a study to
say that. You just have have to have a
little bit of biological logic.
Biological logic to understand that.
Okay, make sense.
Where what happened to AJ? How come I
don't see him?
>> Well, he's here. He's in the gallery.
>> Oh, he's in the gallery. Okay, good. All
right. So, I'm I'm ready to take some
questions if you have.
>> And then AJ, if you want to post that
article if you're if you're listening,
that'd be great. the one that I sent you
on leaky gut and chronic disease.
>> Okay, we'll make sure to post them. And
if it doesn't get posted during the
show, I'll go in and post them after the
show.
>> Okay, thank you. There's a
>> hi AJ.
>> And Marilyn has her hand up. So Marilyn,
oops, I accidentally hit the wrong
button. Marilyn, you have to unmute
yourself. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
>> Okay. Um, if someone has a bad
infection, doesn't really matter where
it is, let's say the bladder
>> and a doctor's got them on antibiotics
>> and they want them on for like let's say
three weeks at least.
>> Is it okay that I introduce like killer
biotic
>> effect? Killer biotics. Killer bias not
killer biotic is not going to do too
much. Yes, you you can definitely
introduce um killer biotic. You mean
added to the antibiotic? Is that Yeah,
that's that's not a problem.
>> That wouldn't be a problem at all. Um
What you want what you want what you
want to do is after you do the
antibiotic you want to do probiotics
>> because antibiotics will kill all the
bacteria. So I'd have to know a little
bit more about the patient but generally
speaking when a patient is on
antibiotics it's a good idea to use
probiotics as well but you don't want to
take them together obviously because the
antib the uh antibiotics will kill the
probiotics. So, if you have probiotics,
if you have antibiotics
and you're taking them like eight every
eight hours, three times a day, between
doses, take some probiotics. Or if you
want to wait till after your your um
your 10 days are up or however long
you're taking them, you can take
probiotics. But one way or another, you
want to introduce probiotics after you
take antibiotics because you're going to
kill off your good bacteria.
>> I was just concerned because it was
going to be like three weeks before he
was going to have some surgery to remove
some um kidney stones.
>> I think killer biotic is basically
herbs, isn't it? It's mushroom extracts.
>> Oh, it's mushroom extracts. No,
>> that's not going to help.
>> No, it's not going to hurt anything.
It's not going to hurt anything.
>> Okay. The probiotics in between.
Fantastic.
>> Yeah.
>> Excuse me.
>> Yes.
>> Ben.
>> Ben,
>> who's that?
>> This is AJ.
I'm sorry. And but what Marilyn is not
mentioning is the bigger issue is the
guy is having surgery to remove kidney
stones. Well, that is a bigger issue.
That's
>> Well, he's having ultrasound.
>> Yeah, but he has he has he's forming
stones.
Okay. Are they oxalate stones?
>> What kind of stones are they?
>> Yeah. So, yeah. So, he's got a he's got
a blood problem
>> and that's really the issue is working
the blood. Now, he didn't ask about
that, so I don't know if you want me to
answer that, but but uh the kidneys
obviously filter the blood, right? So,
um, when you have stone formation in the
kidneys, what you're basically looking
at is super saturated blood. And it
should come as no surprise to anybody
who has oxalates. Oxalates are, by the
way, a waste product. And so, when
people and they're also found in foods.
So oxalates can build up in the kidneys
or in various parts of the body actually
uh when you're producing when your cells
are producing lots of waste when they're
under duress.
And so um the main toxicity or the main
the main uh stressors on cells that
cause it to produce a lot of waste,
believe it or not, is sugar. And
fructose and glucose are intimately
linked to oxalates, which means
diabetes. And we know that or dislycemia
we'll say and we know that dislycemia
can also cause um can also cause uh can
also cause oxalates. So between ox
between dislycemia you probably have a
likely cause of oxalates and you have a
likely cause of kidney disease which
means this is a patient who should be on
the healthy healthy blood sugar pack.
>> Right. Can I ask you what do you think
about potassium citrate?
>> It's awesome. In fact that's one of the
best treatments for oxalates. oxalates
um al alkalinizing the urine is one
natural way to um to uh uh break up
kidney stones and potassium citrate is
an is a alkalinizing agent.
>> So
>> So can I get that just like anywhere
anywhere?
>> Yeah, you can get anywhere.
>> I had just heard something about it. So
excellent.
>> What's that?
>> I had just read something about it.
>> Yeah, I was looking into things for this
gentleman.
And I heard that it actually can
dissolve stones and actually prevent
them from reoccurring.
>> Yeah, alkalinizing the urine is the is
the strategy.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Thank you, Marilyn.
All right. And Haddie has her hand up
and she has a question.
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome. Hey Jeffy, before I ask my
question, so Ben, with regards to the
the recent question about potassium and
um the stones,
uh if you if you're doing an alkalizing
diet, would that be efficient or no?
>> It might help. If you have an alkalizing
diet, you're typically your your urine
will be alkaline as well. and and um
raising the urinary pH is a tried and
trueue strategy for for reducing the
risks of oxalate stones and inhibiting u
crystallization.
>> A so so Ben I I was attempting to have a
client get on but they had a conflict
with the time but he just got diagnosed
with colon cancer vegetarian
>> and he is uh he's he has a bag now.
>> Oh that's terrible. his oncologist.
>> No, they haven't done any surgery,
anything. No chemo, no surgery. They
just like, "Well, we'll see what
happens." And he's like, "Well, I'm
going to do it a natural way." So, they
say, "Cool, man. Do whatever you want to
do." So, he's uh he's doing two things.
He he wants to take the minerals uh
because he gives how important that is.
However, and in addition to that, he
wants to take on,
you know, the emotions is a big part of
any disease. So he believes that his
colon cancer is a product of past life.
>> Well, I don't know about past Well,
>> okay. So, first of all, yes, it is a
product of past life, but not past life
before this life. Past life, this life.
You know what I'm saying? It wasn't like
when he was, you know, Julius Caesar in
ancient Rome. It was like when he was
five years old or 10 years old or 15
years old. So, yes, past life, but past
this life. And by the way, there's no
time. So there's no past life,
right? Physics, we know in phys physics,
according to physics, time is an
illusion. So past lives are an illusion.
However, there are parallel lives. uh if
you want to believe things like you know
uh there was a guy named Hugh ever who
came out with the many mansions
hypothesis in physics and he said that
anything that's possible is happening
all everything's happening all the
everything that could possibly happen is
always happening and that's called the
many many worlds hypothesis I think he
calls it this guy Everett for his first
name but anyway everything's happening
all at once so we can according to the
theory anyway we can be influenced by
things that are happening in parallel
lives versus past lives however However,
that's not that's neither here nor
there. He wants to work on his body now.
Doesn't matter what's happening in a
parallel or past life. He's he's the guy
with the colon cancer. So colon the
colon processes food. So it's not it
shouldn't be a surprise to anybody that
colon cancer rates are increasing
dramatically, especially in young
people, even though doctors are
mystified and they can't figure out why.
between the kind of foods we eat, the
chlorine in our water and the fluoride
in our water which kills the bacteria,
um the uh antibiotics and fish and meat
and and dairy products. There's all
kinds of reasons why our colons are
messed up in this life, not in parallel
or past lives and that means there's
lots he can do. I26
food diary and it's interesting he said
that he's a vegetarian by the way
because we have not so much people on
this call probably but as a culture we
have this idea that veget vegetables are
kind and gentle and benign and meat is
meat is terrible and aggressive and
toxic and uh and associated with
diseases and as it turns out nobody's
there's no meat that anybody's allergic
to but there's lots of plant materials
that people can be allergic to or
intolerant to. So, um, vegetarianism is
not a way to protect yourself against
colon disease, as anybody who has celiac
disease can tell you, uh, which is a
gluten a gluten intolerance disease. Uh,
and there's no gluten in meat.
Okay. So, let me ask you one other
question that he's uh was concerned
about because,
you know, but people anyway because he
believes he anyway. So, the vegetarian
piece is like, well, how do I get colon
cancer? I I have a p pristine diet. I
don't
>> No, he doesn't have that's what tell me
I know. No, no, no. I I get that. I get
that. But I just want you speak to it
because that's his
>> It's not It's not a Yeah, that's what
that was why I said that because I know
people think that. That's the thought is
that oh, I eat I'm vegetarian. I can't
have any kind of disease because I only
eat vegetables.
>> No, it doesn't work that way. Vegetables
don't want to be eaten. And so they
protect themselves by making chemicals
that punish the person who eats them.
That's what gluten is. They call them
lectins collectively. Lectins are plant
defense
molecules. And they're found in all
kinds of vegetables and fruits. And
also, by the way, there's another
molecule called histamine that's found
in so-called good foods like avocados
and bananas and and seafood. So, you
know, you got to go by your particular
reactions. And and very importantly, do
you know this guy, by the way?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, very importantly, you should
ask him, does he have a history of
digestive problems? People don't just
get colon cancer spontaneously out of
the blue. They got to have a history of
something. A history of bloating, gas,
discomfort. you know, he he he had to
have symptoms before he was diagnosed as
colon cancer, which and pretty dramatic
ones to have cancer and he was just
missing them. And so that just
highlights the the whole fact of doing a
food diary, of paying attention to your
body's symptoms, watching how you react
to specific foods, just really being a
participant in your own biochemistry.
not a participant in your own
biochemistry. You're going to end up
being carved up or or medicated by the
medical model. We have to participate in
how our body responds to our li our
lifestyle. Lifestyle whether it's eating
or sedentary or or smoking or drinking
is the main reason why we break down.
the so-called genetic or heredity
component is a sliver compared to
lifestyle compared to how we live our
lives.
>> A Ben let me ask you one quick question
for me.
>> Yes.
>> About histamines.
>> I am seriously dealing with
um you know glycom cataracts and my
vision is really suffering. However,
I'm one of these people that love
avocados. I don't feel like I get a
thingy, you know, get a response to it,
but I have been told that that's not a
food I should eat.
>> Not necessarily. You got to see how you
respond to it. But avocados are a high
histamine food. So, um I'm not going to
tell you your cataracts are caused by
histamine, but histamine is inflam is a
is a inflammatory molecule
>> and it will change fluid balance
anywhere in the body. So, it could be
related to eye problems. I don't know
definitively. Um, but avocados are not
just, you know, like I said, bananas,
strawberries, cherries, um, spinach,
>> all right,
>> pickled vegetables, eggplant, tomatoes,
pasta, you know, pizza, cheese, all
these are high histamine foods.
chocolate, wine, you know, go online and
look up high histamine foods and you'll
be surprised because it'll be more than
likely it'll be foods that you spend a
lot of time eating.
>> Most people do.
>> Low histamine foods or meat meats are
low histamine foods. Fresh fish are low
histamine. Butter is low histamine. Um,
uh, what's apples, pears, blueberries,
those can be low histamine. Um, what
else? Um, quinoa is low histamine.
Lettuce, cabbage, those are low
histamine foods.
>> Yeah, I eat them all.
>> Okay.
>> The high ones and the low ones.
Okay. A. Thank you, dear.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you so much, Hattie. And AJ has
his hand up.
>> And of course, the Daily with Doc
hotline is ringing as as we are
answering questions. So hopefully
there's someone else on the team who can
answer this question.
>> Okay.
>> Um for Mrs. Ben, I'm going to ask a
question for our friends
Allan and Ella. Uh Allan, uh you've
you've talked with him in the past. This
question is today Allan's got a series
of health challenges that he's
overcoming. Uh but he drops off to sleep
a lot. And
>> I'm sorry, say that say that again. Say
the first part of that again before he
drops off to sleep. So Allan's got a a
series of health question uh health uh
issues that he's been trying to overcome
and including
um
he's got a uh machine on the heart to
help for
u what do they call it in infraction.
>> Infarction myioardial infuction.
>> Yes sir. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because I was gonna say infraction which
is not the case. What kind of What kind
of machine did you say he has?
>> It's a It's one that delivers some sort
of liquid that that helps with the with
the infuction
to help
>> like a drug. Like it delivers a drug.
>> Yeah. Uh mtranone.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um I think didn't
we didn't we talk about this on Monday?
>> We we've talked about it in the past if
it wasn't Monday. But um uh but what
causes him to fall off to sleep a lot
and he when he walks he walks with a
walker. He's got um you know uh some
fluid buildup. What what can he do?
>> Well, the strategy for treating
myocardial inffections is to slow the
heart down.
The thinking is the heart works too
hard. You don't want the heart to work
too hard. If you have heart disease,
right? And a myioardial inffection is
like a heart attack. You have heart
disease. The thinking, the logic is slow
down the heart. Well, if you slow down
the heart, you're going to have less
blood going to all the organs. That
means you're going to have less oxygen,
less nutrition, and more toxicity, and
less electricity. So, of course, you're
going to be tired. That's how all these
drugs work. They slow that's how cardiac
drugs work. Not all of them, but a lot
of them work by slowing down the heart.
uh beta blockers, they block the beta
nerves, calcium channel blockers, they
block the flow of calcium into the
heart. So the logic is the thinking is
let's
tell the heart to stand out, but I mean
obviously you're going to be tired after
that. That shouldn't be a surprise to
anybody. So you know if you if you're
interacting with the medical, you don't
want to get to a point where you have to
interact with the medical model. That's
what we're here to to help people with.
Yeah, we talk to people who are sick and
that's important, but I don't want to
just talk to people who are sick. I want
to talk to people who are healthy so
they don't get sick or who are a little
sick but don't want to get worse.
Because once you're have a heart attack,
now you're in, you know, excuse don't
mean to be gross about it, but you're in
bed with the medical model and that
means you're going to be doing whatever
they want you to do, whatever they tell
you to do. And you don't want to get to
that point. Once you're at that point,
yeah, there's things you could do. I
would give I would be putting this guy
on the healthy brain and heart pack as
soon as possible, you know, and I'd be
telling them to take some extra nasin,
probably extra selenium,
um, extra ultimate EFA. I'd probably put
them on the fucoid Z, probably some MSM
sulfur, ultimate zinc, and CFX. There's
a lot you could do uh with nutrition,
but once you have a a heart attack, you
know, that's when you have to go to the
doctor and that's really not in your
interest. Even if they can save your
life, and they do save lives, people
have heart attacks, you know, a lot of
folks who would have been dead 30, 40,
50 years ago, you know, they're alive,
it's still not high quality of life, and
you don't want to get to that point.
>> He's they're thinking about asking a
doctor to get them off this drip.
The problem is is his heart may not be
able. They may need to do that. I and I
don't know the answer. Only he would
know. But I can tell you this. If this
guy were to start taking a lot of
nutrition, that would make his drugs
work more effectively. So, he may not
need as much drugs. And that's a really
important point. I know we talk about it
all the time. nutrients will make the
drugs they're taking more effective as a
general rule which will allow you to
take less less drug to get the same
effect and that's always in your
interest.
>> So they should be putting their uh tangy
tangerine in a blender and maybe eating
beets.
>> Beets. That's a Yeah, that's a good one.
I forgot about that. Yeah. Anything that
helps with nitric oxide, arginine,
beets, vitamin C, all of these are
nitric ox. All of these will support
nitric oxide. Nitric oxide is a
vasoddilator. It improves perfusion or
blood uh blood supply to the heart.
>> And um Okay. So, in your opinion,
you don't know enough to say whether
>> I don't know. I don't know
>> whether he's strong enough to to get off
of this.
>> I don't know if he's strong enough. But
I can tell you he he needs the healthy
brain heart pack.
>> He needs heart nutrients
>> and and the healthy brain heart pack is
not it's yes we we market for the heart
but the nutrients are going to help you
with your immune system, help you your
skin, help you with your digestive
system. They'll help you with
everything. That's how nutrients work.
You know, drugs work by targeting
specific parts of the body. Nutrients
will help specific parts of the body,
but they'll work systemically as well.
They'll help the whole system.
All right, I'll be back with another
question after Marilyn. I'll be a
gentleman today.
>> Okay,
>> you're always a gentleman. All right,
Marilyn, go ahead and ask unmute and I
will
>> I wanted to know your take on this now.
I've only done this for two months, but
the only thing I've changed
>> Yeah.
>> and I'm pretty regular with my diet.
>> Yeah. I have take gotten completely off
of all pasteurized dairy and complete
raw everything raw. And I have taken
also raw seaweed and my energy is
through the roof.
>> It Yeah, it could be a lot
>> times difference.
>> Yeah, it could be a lot of things. It
could be um the nutrients and seaweed is
loaded with nutrients packed with
everything including minerals um and
electrical minerals, ionic minerals. So
that that could be those also um raw
dairy has enzymes in it and it could be
the enzymes that you're getting from raw
dairy or it could be the the the amino
acids or the proteins that you're
getting from raw dairy. So there's no
way to know but yes, it could definitely
be related.
>> Have you heard this too? I read on
pasteurization that there's these
extracellular vesicles that actually are
destroyed with the pasteurization by 60
to 90% and they affect your immune
response. The messenger RNA
>> absolutely ex everything. Pasteurization
kills everything that's alive.
>> Exoomes aren't really alive, but um
homogenization might might have an
effect on them.
>> Pasteurization is heat basically. So it
kills it destroys enzymes. Um and then
they do it so it will kill bacteria. You
know bacteria and milk are a big
problem. There's a there's every state
has a uh agriculture a board of
agriculture an agriculture board that
regulates dairy products and every state
um agriculture board
has something called or or um regulates
the amount of pus that's in milk. It's
called the pus count. And all milk is
allowed to have a certain amount of pus.
Pus cells. Where does the pus come from?
From the uters. Utters get infected.
Cows utters get infected because cows
are getting milked all the time. And
that's a lot a lot of stress on an
udder. And so cows utters get affected.
This is one of the reasons why cows get
antibiotics. Uh and then inevitably no
matter what there's going to be some pus
in the milk and there's allowable levels
of pus in milk. So, um,
>> can I say something?
>> Pasteurization. Pasteurization is
designed to kill bacteria. Yes. Go
ahead. I'm sorry.
>> Last Friday, Jonathan Emore, who's, uh,
Dr. Wallock's constitutional attorney
that fought with the FDA.
>> Yes.
>> Great.
>> He said that you actually he said
actually pasteurization and
unpasteurization. There's been E.coli in
unpasteurized milk, but then there's
been salmonila cases. Many
>> in unpasteur in pasteurized milk.
>> In pasteurized milk. Yes. And he says,
"So the FDA cannot really use that
argument."
>> Well, the salmonella in pasteurized milk
is in the milk after it's been
pasteurized.
The pasteurization process will kill
salmonella, but salmonillaa can be in
milk after it's pasteurized.
>> Right.
>> I'm pretty sure that I I may be wrong on
that. Maybe Jonathan knows something. I
don't know. But I would think
pasteurization would kill salmonella.
>> Well, and he said something. He said
like raw milk is a company that puts out
a lot of the raw products and he said
for them to just change their label and
say you can pasteurize your own milk but
you are at risk. This is if you're going
to eat this, you could be exposed to a
kilo salmonilla.
>> Right.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I'm say that again. I
didn't understand.
>> John said that you should they can
change the label on the milk and say
that more or less you are at risk if you
eat drink this milk.
>> It's unpasteurized, but you can
pasteurize it yourself
by heating it.
>> Yeah, that's true. But you have to heat
it to a high temperature. But but what's
I don't understand what you said about
salmonella. I didn't get that. Um,
that's what Jonathan Moore just said
that
>> I didn't understand.
>> He just said that there was a lot of
pasteurization pasteurized milk that had
salmon milk cases.
>> That could that could be, but the
pasteuriza that would happen after it
was pasteurized. I would think
>> I heard what you said.
>> Yeah, I I would think unless I unless I
I can't imagine pasteurization would not
kill all bacteria because it's pretty
high heat that they use. They basically
boil it.
>> Yes. and some to 302 degrees Fahrenheit
I found for like six seconds.
>> Yeah, that's pretty high heat.
>> Yeah, they destroys every anything alive
will be destroyed by that.
>> Okay. Okay. Thank you. Thank you so
much, Marilyn.
>> Good questions. All right. And so um
Mary has a question and
>> Mary
>> I will bring her on and if you can
unmute Mary and then
I'll have a question after Mary because
she may be asking the one I was going to
say could be could be could be I'm
bringing in a question.
>> What's up Mary?
>> Hey how you doing
>> good. How are you? Good to see you
>> going to the beach soon. Hey, uh, we
have a question I brought in from
YouTube from Olga.
Olga wants to know, "What does
pharmacist Ben think about A2 milk?"
>> It's for people have problems with uh A2
milk is a is a kind of milk that doesn't
have the allergenic proteins. And so for
people who have milk allergies, it can
be good. It's there's nothing wrong with
it.
>> Okay. But still has the same
>> issues that you've mentioned. No, it
won't have it's less allergenic.
>> Okay.
>> It's less allergenic. Um but yeah, the
salmonella issues or the back the
pasteuriz It's still pasteurized,
>> right?
>> It's less allergenic for people have
milk allergies.
>> Okay. Okay. All right. Well, that was
really the question.
>> Is this person person have milk
allergies or what's the deal?
>> Uh Olga did not say um she might put
something in back in YouTube, but that
was uh one of the
>> Okay. A2 I just wanted to
>> A2 milk
>> ask
>> is made with just A2 a type of protein
called cassine which is milk protein.
Most milk is A1 plus A2
>> right?
>> And A2 milk is just um uh it just
contains A2 cassine which is um marketed
as being less um less distressful on the
on the digestive tract, less bloating
and such.
Okay, gotcha. Okay, I'll turn that over
to Ruth Ellen or RJ. Ruth Ellen,
>> thank you, Mary. And that was the
question I was going to ask. So, thank
you so much. Um, and Marilyn Bruce says,
Marilyn, that is why we call you fingers
because you are always going 100 miles
per hour and you have a lot of energy.
Lol.
There you go.
So AJ does have a question, so I'm going
to bring him on and
>> I'll keep looking for questions. And I
have another one, but we're gonna let AJ
go first.
>> All right, Thomas Ben. So I got a
question in uh that came in uh from
someone that uh we uh connected with in
Florida. Um
>> was it Ally? I got to call Ally.
>> That was Ally.
>> Yeah, I owe Ally a phone call. Is Ally
on the call?
>> Ally is not on the call.
>> Okay, I got to call Ally.
>> Uh her her dad's got uh constant D uh
it's got constant internal bleeding.
>> Where is he bleeding from? Do they know?
>> I'm gonna I'm gonna assume it's the
dadum.
>> Well, that's a that's a serious problem.
Internal bleeding. And uh they they put
them on uh some radiation
on
>> they don't Yeah. They don't you got to
figure out what the bleeding like what's
causing the dadinal issues. Forget the
bleeding. What's causing the intestinal
issues?
>> Uh I I
I you know based on things that you and
Dr. Wall have said in the past, I
mentioned to them they might want to get
some Pepto-Bismol
and uh I also obviously uh suggested
um you know that they had to improve the
stomach acid. Um you know,
>> dando bleeding is like an emergency
thing,
>> but they keep releasing them out of the
hospital. So I I mean so it's it's like
an emergency thing, but they you know
they they they treat him. He bleeds his
blood.
>> Does he have an ulcer? Does he have an
ulcer?
>> Uh I couldn't tell you, but he's got
some sort of cancer, right? So uh
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. You know he has
cancer?
>> He's got cancer and it's in in the
cheek. It's in it's in the intestine.
It's it's
>> Okay, got it. So he's got cancer all
over his body
>> at this point. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. So then that means the
cancer is in his circulatory system and
it's metastasized.
>> Correct.
>> Spread. Okay. So, you know, that's
that's pretty serious.
>> Spread since
obviously some of the interventions that
they've done.
>> Yeah. Well, that's he's deteriorating.
That's that's not a good thing at all.
Um, you know, there's a lot if you look
cancer is tricky because once you have
cancer, it doesn't just happen. It takes
a long time for cancer to develop. That
means the body has been under duress.
Specifically, cells have been under
duress for a long time. With the
exception of like ionizing radiation
where you get you get blasted with
electrical energy, cancer is just a long
it takes a long time for it to develop,
relatively long time for it to develop.
That means you got to be mucking up the
work severely and chronically in order
for cancer to show up, especially if
it's now it's metastasized.
So, you know, at this point, and for
anybody who has cancer that's met that's
that has um developed to the point where
it's now metastasized, you have to be
very kind to the body. That's the
strategy. And kindness to the body means
none none of the bad stuff. And the bad
stuff could be things that you think are
good. Like we talked about earlier, you
have to see how you react. And in fact,
foods in general are stressful on the
body. Anything we eat will cause
something called postrandial
inflammation.
Anything. There are people who react to
lettuce, you know, but especially if you
have complex foods, complex fats or
complex proteins or processed fats,
heavily processed proteins, you got to
make absolutely sure you're eliminating
those as well as uh reducing your
calories in general. That's the main
strategy for dealing with cancer and
dealing with uh particularly digestive
cancers. Now, there are doctors who
don't like the idea of reducing your
calories. They think you're going to
waste away, but as we've said many
times, it's not a calorie issue. It's a
muscle issue. And so, when you reduce
your calories, you can actually build
muscle. The ketogenic diet and lowc
calorie diets are strategies that
bodybuilders use to get cut up. So
building muscle um or build uh gaining
weight is not really you don't really
necessarily want to gain fat weight.
People on cancer they're always told or
a lot of them are told don't fast
because you're getting too skinny etc.
I'm not sure I buy into that because
when you put a lot of calories in the
body, you've now diverted
resources to process those calories and
those are resources that you should be
using to fight your cancer and now
you're using them to digest your
hamburgers. So, seems like a no-brainer.
You'd rather use your nutrients to fight
disease and to digest your food. That
means eat less food. Uh there's also the
fucoid Z. There's also vitamin C, the
CFX. Um, there's the restart your life.
What else? Ultimate selenium. These are
all have protective effects against
cancer. Ultimate zinc. Um,
pretty much all nutrients are going to
have some protective effects against
cancer, but specifically the ones we
just talked about, C and and zinc and
selenium and fucoid Z and restart your
life, which is beta glucan. So, you're
not automatically saying like I I I
would have thought you would have said,
>> which is that because he's got this
internal this constant internal
bleeding, but there's got to be some
sort of ulcerative thing going on.
>> Yeah, I'm assuming there is some kind of
ulcerative either a pepsic ulcer or a
dadinal ulcer.
>> Okay. So,
>> but I'm sure I assume that I assume they
checked for that.
>> Well, um I don't know if it's a language
barrier. I'm not entirely sure that they
feel that they've gotten good answers
from their physician.
>> Stop eating or eat less food. A lot less
food. Not stop. You have to eat
obviously, but eat less food.
>> And get your nutrients from supplements
instead of from calories. That's
remember that's the one of the main
benefits that we don't talk about
supplementation is that you get
nutrients without calories. Calories
need work. Calories are heat. Calor
means heat. So calories require work to
kind of cool the body down. After you
eat, the body gets hot. Calories, not
necessarily hot. Actually, you can
actually feel heat. If you have you ever
eaten a lot of food, overeating, and you
can feel kind of heat, especially sugar,
>> without overeating. Yes. You you you
warm up, you know, that's why you
>> you can actually feel it. Yeah, you can
actually feel it. Particular if you eat
a lot. So all of that, it puts a stress
on the body. So eating less food is
definitely an important strategy for for
GI issues. All GI issues. Anything
really. We eat too much.
>> Everybody eats too much. I eat too much.
>> I eat too much. You know what we're
gonna talk about on Monday?
>> Eating too much.
>> That's a good idea. But no.
>> No.
>> You know what we're going to talk about
on Monday?
>> No idea.
>> Gonna talk about why you shouldn't get
those dog on tattoos.
>> Oh,
those tattoos. Huh. That's interesting.
Every man, every kids these days. Holy
cow.
>> Kids, adults,
>> the kids. I mean, that my interns, they
got tattoos here.
>> Everywhere. Everywhere. Tattoos are all
here. This where the lymph is.
>> Is that Is that where it is?
>> Yeah. All the lymph is up here. You see
people getting tattoos all in this area.
It's
>> dangerous stuff, man.
>> Thank you, AJ. And Haddie has her hand
up, so Haddie unmute.
There we go. There we go. I apologize.
>> That's okay.
>> You know, I was so involved in listening
to the discussion, I forgot what the
heck I wanted to say.
>> Um,
that is sinful.
Oh, no. There it is. There it is. My
niece, she just can't. She She's in the
hospital right now. Uh, they just put
her on dialysis. She was she she called
me up and she says, "Listen, I don't
want to go on diialysis." So, we put her
on the program. But
>> how old is your niece?
>> She is, man, she's going to be 60 in a
couple days.
>> Oh wow. Um, diabetes or dislycemia.
Dislymia means messed up blood sugar.
Diabetes is the brand name. Dislymia
very common, very common in
African-Americans, too, by the way. Uh,
and there may be some a relationship
between vitamin D uh and uh dislycemia.
African-Americans are typically going to
have lower vitamin D levels than
Caucasians because
>> there's a relationship between churches
fried chicken and
>> 100%. 100% absolutely churches fried
chicken and sweets and all of that. That
is true. Um I'm not blaming melanin or
dark skin for it, but that is one that's
one thing that's been associated with
things like prostate health issues,
blood pressure issues, heart disease,
and diabetes. And vitamin D is a vitamin
D is important for every single
biological function there is. And
vitamin D deficiencies will likewise
cause problems with every single
biological function there is. So vitamin
D can be helpful first of all and then
treat treat her like a diabetic. Healthy
brain healthy blood sugar pack. And also
Rebecca, I don't know if AJ or if
Marilyn or Ruth Allen if you guys have
Rebecca's protocol. She has a really
cool protocol she got from doc for
reversing um reversing kidney disease.
>> Yes, we can get that.
>> Yeah, you should get that.
From what I hear, uh it works pretty
darn well. I haven't I've just heard
from Rebecca, but from what I heard,
it's a very effective protocol.
>> Start working on it.
>> Thank you, Haddie.
Thank you, Hattie, very much.
All right, let me
All right, this is really good. I'm
enjoying this.
>> Okay. All right.
>> I'm looking to see if we have any more
questions.
We might get you out of here a little
early.
>> Yeah, I got tons to do.
>> So, I know you do. So, I want to talk
about thin for a minute.
>> Thon is I just love that stuff. I do
too.
>> I'm in love with that vitamin. Vitamin
B1 for those uh new folks. And it's also
the first vitamin to be discovered. And
I'm not going to tell the story again
because I tell it every time almost, but
it's a really really fascinating story
how Bamin was discovered.
>> Okay. How how was it discovered? No,
>> no, I don't want to tell that story. I
tell it every time.
>> So, um I was watching this TV show and
um I forget what it's called. Um but
anyway,
the main character character's father,
they thought he had um uh dementia or
Alzheimer's and because he wasn't
remembering things and he couldn't think
clearly and they work at some kind of um
like
um it's like a camp that you could go
stay at by the lake and um they sell
thin,
bottles of thin for
So the mosquitoes won't eat them.
>> Come on. Seriously?
>> Yes. I swear that's on the TV show.
Okay. That's on the TV show.
>> Where did you hear that?
>> On the TV show.
>> Where did you hear that before?
>> I me I used to make thamin I used to
make a thamin cream for people when they
were went camping.
>> Perfect. I want something.
>> Yeah. Well, the problem is you got to
thamin has sulfur in it and it breaks
down and it makes your cream stink after
a while. So you have to use fresh. But
yes, thoses hate thamin.
>> Yes.
>> And when you take thamin, it comes
through your it comes through your sweat
and it'll keep mosquitoes from biting
you. Or you can have you make your own
thamin cream for that matter. You can
just break open a thamin capsule
>> and and dissolve the powder in a cream.
It dissolves right in the cream and you
can make your own. But you do have to
use it fresh.
>> Yes. So anyway, she was giving the
product to somebody and then she
realized because she was a doctor. Oh my
gosh. So they give it to the father and
>> wait, is this a is this a TV show? Is it
>> It's a TV show.
>> Okay. Got it. Got it. Got it. Okay. So
they they were using a thamin pill for
mosquitoes, but his heart his heart
disease improved. Did you hear his head
memory?
>> He was very deficient because he sold it
to people. Anyway, I just wanted to see
that's that's a real thing. The
mosquitoes.
>> Oh yeah, it's a real thing. Yeah. I it's
all I'm telling you. I made I used to
make thyon cream for people, but anybody
can make their own thyon cream.
>> Oh, AJ.
>> Yeah, this is some interesting stuff.
Bungen on um
on uh Rumble.
>> Yeah. Hi, Bun.
>> He he emailed in and he says, "Hello,
team from a long time friend of the
show. What causes baldness?"
What causes baldness?
Um, a lot of things cause baldness, but
one of the main things is oxidation
inside a follicle.
Now, to the body, the hair in the head
doesn't matter as much as the heart or
the liver or the intestines or the lungs
or the viscera inside the body. So under
conditions of nutritional deficiencies,
nutrients will be shunted away from the
scalp and the skin for that matter
towards the uh interior of the body. So
you can bypass those by supplement all
your supplements. That's first of all.
Second of all, there's a very important
relationship between hormones and um
baldness, estrogen, thyroid hormone,
progesterone, testosterone, cortisol.
All of these hormones will play a role
in how healthy your hair is. So, keeping
your blood sugar stable, reducing stress
hormone, using progesterone,
cream, topical is the best way. You also
get pills if you want. And then, um
reducing your exposure if you're male,
reducing your exposure to estrogen. Uh
if you're a woman, um making sure you're
metabolizing estrogen or processing
estrogen correctly. estrogen that's not
processed will not only build up but it
will turn into a super estrogen form and
that can be associated with um with with
baldness as well or actually I shouldn't
say that the drop in estrogen that can
occur postmenopausal after menopause or
um or after uh you have your men after
you have a baby that can cause baldness.
Estrogen on its own simp just in a
vacuum is associated with nice beautiful
hair. However, if estrogen is not
processed correctly or if you're a real
high estrogen producer, eventually your
thyroid will slow down and that will
cause um that will cause baldness as
well. Hypothyroidism, poorly functioning
thyroid will cause your hair to fall
out. So, there's a lot of there's a lot
of pieces here. If you want a protocol,
what I would do is focus on blood sugar,
which is the major link between
estrogen, testosterone,
and uh the health of your hair, the
health of your scalp. So, I would be
focusing on blood sugar, treating myself
like a diabetic, using the healthy blood
sugar pack. Uh ultimate EFAs will allow
you to get estrogenic benefits without
having to use a lot of estrogen. You can
also use topical progesterone if you
like. Um and then also anything you can
do to support digestive health that will
improve that will help you with your uh
absorption of nutrients. That's a really
important point. We know when you have
Crohn's disease or celiac disease or the
gentleman who had that dodinal ulcer uh
remember if you have an intestinal
problem you're also likely to be
malabsorbing
which means now you've got another
problem which not only can make your
intestinal problem worse but can cause
any other any other health issue. So
intestinal problems are especially
problematic because not only is that how
toxins get into the blood, but they're
also going to be associated with poor
absorption of nutrients, which is going
to make you less equipped to be able to
handle the toxicity that's getting into
your blood. So intestinal intestinal
issues typically have a one-two punch
depending on how severe they are.
Uh for uh interesting when you when you
started off uh when you when you
mentioned a simple answer might have
been uh
the fact that the body needs nutrients
for important things and you know the
hair is not so important to the body. So
that's one of the last things that gets
the nutrients. Adrian said something
identical yesterday.
>> Adrien Gold.
>> Yes, she did.
>> She's awesome. What did she What did she
say?
>> Something identical to what you just
said. But what what what I'm what I'm
getting at is we got people like you. We
got people like Ellen. We got people
like Adrien Gold and Al Mary and Marilyn
and Phyllis, of course, and and all the
other folks who are watching in the room
and on YouTube,
etc. But are are we enough? Do we need
more people? So, heck yeah. We need an
army.
>> We need an army, AJ.
>> We can't just do it on our own.
>> We can't do it on our own. I can't do it
on my own. Come on. You know, even you
can't do it on your own. You're amazing.
No, we need help.
>> Can you teach? Are we able to teach?
>> Yes.
>> What we do?
>> Yes. Absolutely.
>> So, what do you suggest they do?
>> Sign up. Call AJ. Call AJ now. If you
want to learn about health, if you want
to learn about nutrition, if you want to
learn how to help your friends and
neighbors and loved ones uh get better
and get healthier, if you want to learn
about the Youngevity products, sign up.
Join the Youngevity mission. Become a
certified health coach. We have
certified health coach program as you
know, uh AJ and Ruth Allen. Participate,
help change the world. You'll make money
too at the same time. But even above and
beyond that, help change the world in a
positive way. Make that your purpose. My
people perish for lack of knowledge.
Hosea 8 800 BC 20 thou three nearly
3,000 years ago. Still happening today.
My people perish for lack of knowledge.
Our opinion leaders in the health field
are not giving us the straight scoop
because they don't know. Not because
they're bad people. They just don't
know. But you there's so much we could
do. We're leaving health on the table.
There's so much we could do to maintain
our good health and to reverse our
diseases. Nobody's telling us this.
That's why these programs are so
important. That's why Dr. Wallace work
is so important. That's why longevity is
so important. All right. I got I got a
bowl.
>> Yes, you do.
>> Thank you guys so much.
>> Thank you. My pleasure as always. We'll
see you on Monday. And bye for now.
>> Bye for now.
Thank you.
All right. That was awesome.
So, if I could get my co-host to come on
up, we can close out the show. Um, I do
want to say that if you did want to
become a certified holistic health
coach, you could go to
coach.dailywithdoc.com
and sign up for the Institute of
Holistic Health and um, join us, you
know, join us on this journey that we're
on. Um, again, our phone number is
855-949-3377.
If you have any questions, we'd like to
talk to a certified holistic health
coach or are interested in joining
Youngevity. We would love to have people
join our team for sure. Also, uh, if you
have health questions or concerns, and
somebody did have a question on YouTube,
but it would have required lots of
questions to get the answer to your
question. So, if you could call uh the
855-949-3377,
which I did post um in YouTube, that
would be really great. Um, also, did I
give it? I'm going to give it again just
in case. uh questions at
dailywithdoc.com
and that would be really a good place to
get questions answered and also please
make sure to include your phone number
because there's a lot of times that we
have questions or need to talk to you.
Um a lot of times it's because email is
weird sometimes as you all know.
So um this program was for educational
purposes only and not meant to treat,
diagnose or cure any diseases or take
the place of your primary care
physician.
And um
so I just we none of us could do this
alone. So we have to have a team and
especially for this show we need a team
for Zoom and for everything. So, um,
Phyllis, who is the first person on my
screen, she is out there on the
different platforms posting,
disclaiming, uh, everything and
creating all kinds of stuff and putting
it out there. And then she's also her
and her husband are responsible for
getting Dr. Wallik on the radio.
None of us would be here if it wasn't
for that. So, thank you so much, Alice.
I
just you have a special thought in my
heart. And then we have Mary who is out
there also on the different platforms
bringing in questions and um
and she is also posting in here. So
she's keeping an eye on a few things and
a very important member of our team.
Thank you so much for all that you do,
Mary. And then we have Albert who's in
South Africa. And I missed you so much
this week. We all did.
He is our gatekeeper and um he lets
people in the Zoom and if somebody's
doing something that's a little funky,
he kicks them out. And also he is a a
member of our phone team that answers
the phone in the middle of the night
when we are all sleeping like babies.
And so thank you for all that you do,
Albert. And then Marilyn, Miss Speedy
Fingers, who types 100 miles an hour.
Thank you for saying that, Bruce. That
was really cool. Um, and she is the best
part of being in the Zoom room besides
being able to like come on and ask
questions is the information that she
posts. So, thank you so much for all
that you do, Marilyn. And then we have
AJ who's part of our tech crew who's the
digital marketing director for our uh
for Daily with Doc and um he does a lot
of things and he's helped encourage us
to push for more and um thank you so
much for all that you do AJ and a big
shout out to Becca Dukes. We miss you
girl and are looking forward to when you
come back and um so have a beautiful
weekend everyone. enjoy it and you know
go outside if it's sunny. Walk in the
sun. It's gorgeous out. The flowers are
blooming and the trees are have full
leaves. Almost all of them are full of
leaves now. And um just remember to be
kind. Always be kind. You never know
what somebody is going through. And you
know sometimes just a smile and a hello
can change somebody's day and even save
a life. There's lots of stories about
that. Thank you again. Have a beautiful,
beautiful day and we'll see you next
week. Have a great day and a good
weekend. Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, for
post-docctors in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.